so you're playing with the Ouija board
Luigi board the idea is it's not your
hands moving the thing around but it's
demons basically it's moving this all
right did it work
so
it's funny because in my first encounter
with the Ouija boards my mom used to
have them as a prop for Halloween no one
played with it it was just one Halloween
parties and she'd just have the Ouija
board there it'll just be a prop right
and um I I think one of the first times
I remember using it and it wasn't like I
did this like hundreds of times it was
maybe a handful of times 70 times and
it's the first time it worked was I was
at a friend's house I was I think like
eighth grade summer or something ninth
grade eighth grade summer and there was
a group of us at this this girl's house
and so it was a group like maybe five or
six was playing it
and it's also a move now you know
everyone's first reaction is it you is
it you is it you everyone's no no I
swear no I promise no everyone's not I
know it's not me the thing starts to
move people start getting freaked out
and me again I'm I'm challenging this
stuff I think it's a joke yeah because
even though I think like oh it really is
moving on its own at this point now but
I'm like asking it stupid questions you
know like oh if you're real show your
face you know and stuff like that and so
it starts to move and people will start
getting freaked out so it was like me
and I think it was like two or three
other girls and another guy they said
and they they start saying one of them
said you have to ask it if you can leave
like I heard you know you can't just or
I'll leave the door door open you have
to ask if you're allowed to leave so
they say can I leave and it goes yes can
I leave yes and so next thing I know
it's just me and this one girl and she
says can I leave and it says no
so she goes to trial and she's like can
I leave no and it goes no no and she
just freaked out and she just like she
just like ran off and I was sitting
there and just laughing and so it wasn't
you moving it and so you could say well
maybe it's this girl just wants to you
know spend more time with you yeah I'm
gonna move it to say no yeah but she
gets very freaked out and then she
leaves no it was genuine fear like she
was like oh my gosh I said no no she
just like freaked out and she left
so that was like the first time I saw
something come from
um and then years later I played it back
when I was getting really into the DMT
uh I just I had one and I was with one
of my friends and this guy was you know
he was a very stoic kind of guy he
wasn't a type of guy to like get scared
easily like me and him used to you know
do all types of crazy stuff together he
wasn't the the type of guy to for one to
to play into it and to to get scared
about stuff like this it's just me and
him you know we're and and we start
playing and like I said I lived on the
that Battlefield and so we started
asking and things that starts moving I
don't even need to ask I knew it wasn't
him he knew it wasn't me he starts
moving so we're asking him multiple
questions
and he's I started asking like well when
am I gonna die what and it gives me it
gives me a number and it says from
overdose says 37 from my overdose then
it's and then he asked it and it gave
him a number and it gave him uh it said
I think like heart failure or something
heart attack or something
to this day that friend is scared he'll
he called me literally like last year he
said he like he freaked out he I mean
that like and this is
2012 2013 I mean this he to this day
he's still afraid of that he still
thinks that's going to happen yeah of
course how old are you I'm 30. yeah are
you scared no no because I I think the
blood broke the curse so
but I think that it would have happened
I think that that was the intention I
think that was the plan for my life
maybe you know
um but he's I mean he still thinks that
like he's he called me actually like a
year ago or something he said dude I
only have a year left if that you know
like he thinks it's gonna happen right
because
demons can't read your mind demons are
not God demons are not omniscient or
anything like that
but they are pretty good observers of
behavior
and So based on the behavior that you
were exhibiting for a long time it may
have been a perfectly reasonable
inference to say oh yeah you'll die at
37 from a drug overdose yeah yeah 100 so
why are you doing because people tell me
this they say oh yeah I play with Ouija
boards and crystals and weird astrology
stuff but it was all just kind of silly
games and I think when I want to play a
silly game I play Monopoly what is it
about
what Drew you to the Ouija board and all
the occult stuff I think just us as
humans we're drawn to the taboo you know
I think it's part of our nature we like
that mystery that that's why people like
horror movies and stuff and it's like
and your inhibitions are already a
little bit weakened because you're doing
all this other great yeah yeah I was
already I liked that that like kind of
that I like the Demonic type of stuff I
was drawn to the dark stuff not uh you
know not in the sense of hey you know
Devil with pitchfork and horns but the
the stuff that made people uncomfortable
I wanted to go into the water that
everyone else was like I don't know it's
a little crazy the secret yeah yeah and
so that was it was just something I did
with like friends I'd play the Ouija
board I started doing the psychics I
started you know I went into all that
because of Buddhism is already kind of
branched that's a I would say those are
branches of that it's like that whole
world kind of comes together
it's the same thinking and so I started
getting more into the the Colton so what
was crazy is when I was
um about 20 2012. I was doing a lot of
psychedelics I was doing a lot of heroin
I was in probably the worst place I had
ever one of the darkest places in my
life and so I had this moment of like
I'm having encounters with light beings
they're why am I not happy
why am I still stuck I can't stop doing
heroin I want to kill myself and I'm
have I'm thinking I'm enlightened I
would have a trip and for a week I'd be
the most enlightened I think I was
Gandhi for the next week I'm Gandhi
everybody and then a week later I want
to kill myself and so I'm starting to
connect these dots like this doesn't
make sense like why why am I having
these great experiences but I can't ever
bring back the the fruit or what I
thought was fruit I can't ever bring it
back to my life and I can't find the
power to overcome any of this my
obstacles what did you think the light
beings were did you think it was a
figment of your imagination you know
just a chemical product of the of the
drugs or did you think they were Angels
or something so with with acid and
mushrooms you don't typically at least I
never had visuals we're like oh I'm
seeing this thing just pop up it's more
like the walls will melt everything's a
lot more vibrant
um
but you know you might you could see
something it starts to look like
something else I had time like my dog
turned dog turned green and his tongue
was longer stuff like that right like
but like you know like oh this is
reality dog yeah yeah yeah like it's
like I knew it was reality with the DMT
this was like full-on like that you're
seeing a whole world just crack open in
front of you it's like going to Mars or
something right like right now this room
you know just turns into you know
another realm right and it's like so I'm
experienced so I knew I was
hallucinating but I also knew 100 this
stuff is real whatever is in my room
right now these things are real and they
they would be light beams so they're
they're a human shape
but they are like um they were colors
one was one was purple one was orange
one was red it's like a flaming light
but in a human shaped body right so it's
like a silhouette and then um the thing
about them is that they would always
um speak peace like we're here to help
you we're you know calm down relax we
have your you know we have your back and
the thing that was interesting and I
didn't pick that up at the time but
looking back
it literally was like you know when
you're swimming in the ocean and you
feel like that there's something maybe
under you it's like you're enjoying the
waves it's fun but you're kind of like
oh there might be a shark that's how it
felt it's like I kind of don't trust you
guys but I don't have a reason not to
you look pretty you're giving me good
information
you're clothed as an angel of Light yeah
yeah and so that's that's kind of where
it was at but um it just never
and they gave you advice in the sense
that calm down it's okay what would they
tell you well they would so like the one
DMT experience I had I had these three
beings come in my room I freaked out I
started to try to get up off the bed but
there was a bigger one like so if I was
laying down
it was like his legs were 10 feet tall
so the other ones I see in front of me
dancing around the swirling this one was
10 like 10 feet tall legs I couldn't
even see the top of the the being but
his hands started going over me and if
you've seen Reiki they go like this like
they do he was doing Reiki hand
movements over me and he was telling me
telepathically relax we're here to help
you right and then a few minutes later
my door opened up by itself and another
one came in it was dragging my body so
I'm in my body I'm watching this my body
gets dragged into the room and they told
me if you don't stop doing heroin this
is you and and because I used to get
high in my bathroom and so I knew they
were saying like you're gonna overdose
in this bathroom if you don't stop and
so that's what I mean like they would
tell me like you need to be a better
person you know so what is that is it
seems to me
there's four options it could be your
subconscious you you knew even as you're
doing a bunch of dope you know that this
is bad for you it's going to kill you so
it's your subconscious telling you that
like in a dream say or their demons
the clothes this angels of light as it
says in the Bible or they're angels
or they're just some weird chemical
hallucination totally random totally
unaccounted for totally meaningless
which to me seems like the most
ridiculous possibility of all
so which of the three is
so I think the interesting thing is if
you talk to anybody that did
psychedelics
I think everybody would agree they're
all real it's it's like it's everybody
it's not just yourself it's not your
imagination your subconscious I think
there's times people think like your
subconscious can create stuff that isn't
really there
but those experiences are 100 and it's
another dimension it is the it's the
veil is removed and I think that's what
gets manipulated because of our
ignorance you know um and so uh and I'll
give you an example the first time I did
the mushrooms I started to climb up a
radio tower and then I got about 20 feet
up and I saw oh what am I doing I
shouldn't be climbing a tower right now
I started to climb down that inflicted a
thought of fear where I started for some
reason because I was in the woods I
started thinking about the Headless
Horseman and I'm like oh the hell this
Horseman's gonna get me I started to
hear I started to uh hear horse horses
come right so that was a a example of me
thinking something right and then it
kind of but I knew oh I'm just tripping
yeah you know like oh this isn't real
right now I went back in the car I was
fine because you hear that expression a
lot be like oh man that guy's tripping
over there yeah obviously where it comes
from is like you literally were tripping
and you were imagining something that
wasn't there yeah and I was imagining it
and I knew I was but this was different
than what was going on in your way
different but so then but my question is
it sounds like they're demons but
they're saying hey don't kill yourself
get off the heroin which seems like good
advice so then it seems like they're
angels right right so what is it that's
the that's the deception in it and so I
think uh Romans 6 talks about it says it
says you're either a slave to sin or the
righteousness it says look at the fruit
of what's coming from this and so I
think that a lot of times we have to
look like what is the fruit that is
coming from this like the the fruit that
was coming from this was not good in any
sense for me even when they say get off
the heroin that's not good well I guess
because it didn't work because it didn't
there was no power there so it was it's
kind of like and I always use this
illustration of if I'm trying to kidnap
somebody I'm not going to say you know
hey I'm here to kill you kid like come
in the car it's like here's some candy
hey I want to get you down there here's
a hundred dollars so they don't if if
you look at like the the state of Satan
being the God of this world in a fallen
State fallen angels having uh you know
secret knowledge and you know what I
mean personalities and Powers Yeah and
all this stuff
they're not dumb you know and so they
can give you stuff that looks good you
know
right yeah right and yeah we I guess our
imagination is just limited we think oh
those stupid little Devils we're so much
smarter than them yeah
no they're pure intelligence you know
they're probably probably more
intelligent than we are oh yeah in many
ways